logan paul finds himself in hot water
again plus it's new music Friday and I
have the T on the new Calvin Harris the
Fifty Shades freed and black panther
soundtracks hey guys happy Friday I need
to give you a quick shout-out because it
was a really good week for us here and a
lot of you watched our videos so thank
you and they said we wouldn't last
alright guys should we get to Logan Paul
it's barely been a month since he was
first suspended by YouTube after posting
a video of a man apparently taking his
own life in Japan so called suicide
forest well YouTube has once again
taking issue with him eats he has
learned the streaming service has
temporarily suspended any ads on his
channel this time after Logan posted a
video tasing dead rats we weren't gonna
show it alright he continued jolting the
rats even after throwing them in the
trash and PETA didn't take that lightly
and neither did you two a spokesperson
told ET in a statement quote this is not
a decision we made lightly however we
believe he has exhibited a pattern of
behavior in his videos that makes his
channel not only unsuitable for
advertisers but also potentially
damaging to the broader creator
community again this is the second time
Logan's advertising privileges were
revoked here's what he told Good Morning
America about the backlash from the
first video and I believe it happened
for a reason
and I think that reason is so I could
take this experience learn from it new
Logan Paul haircut same old Logan Paul
Bodhi you guys think did he go a little
too far with this rat thing let us know
in the comments all right but no more
talk of rats let's get into our new
music Friday playlist this week
Calvin Harris is back with his new
single not ready no ready
featuring partynextdoor and while I
think that title is terrible
the song is a jam
industry and remember we have to run
from my body gotta decimal
don't want me to know nothing
[Music]
I'm into this because it's kind of
unexpected Calvin keeps on surprising us
going in different directions with his
music but he's not always a fan of his
new stuff
Calvin recently stopped by zane lowe's
beats one show on Apple music and said
he wasn't the biggest fan of his 2016
song my way which was rumored to be a
buzz exterior Swift yeah you know what
it's more just like I feel quite
liberated at the moment you know every
note I think what happened to me was
that at the end that's why 16 approach
you know and it did alright I was on my
way it said all right and then I was
thinking about a nice thing about what
I'm gonna do for the next song is gonna
be and who's it going to be where's
umbrella and I realized I wasn't really
that excited about that song for the
first time in you know 11 years I wasn't
that excited about a song that comment
was IRI
something something's wrong here well
he's vibing on this next step so good on
you Calvin
alright he's a British import as is our
next artist do Oliva I just saw her in
LA last night still not fully recovered
thankfully I woke up to a new pop from
my British pop princess this one is off
the Fifty Shades freed soundtrack called
hi
[Music]
that one's dope and another soundtrack
that just dropped today is the Black
Panther album courtesy of Kendrick Lamar
who curated the whole thing and thank
goodness he did because it is fire one
of my favorite tracks is could leave the
ways with suede
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
some easy-listening for your weekend
right there so there you have it alright
thanks again for watching don't forget
you guys can catch up on all the stories
from this week over at ET online.com
forward slash daily denny i'll see you
guys on Monday
[Music]